hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Five Nights at
Freddy's security breach ruin so what
we're going to be doing now is we're
going to be getting whatever this thing
is with the doors there's been doors and
security cameras I opened every single
one of them that I saw and even going
through this whole game again and
checking all the cameras I saw that
there were more than there were before
now also I need to make sure that I
still get all the Collectibles because
I've collected all the Collectibles and
pretty much everything and I just need
to make sure that I actually have them
speaking of I need to pull that up not
distractible no not distractible my
podcast with Bob and Wade that if you
haven't heard of it you should check it
out Link in the description below oh
there is a collectible that requires
okay
oh boy okay so I would literally have to
activate external cheats to be able to
get no clip uh so I won't hold myself to
that standard so there's one collectible
that I didn't get but it's bugged it's
not my fault so uh not my problem anyway
time to go through this
yeah
doesn't really look familiar
doesn't this look extremely like
in space with markiplier you don't know
what I'm talking about boy have you
missed out did you know did you know I'm
making an iron lung movie
new trailer soon
right here
oh
boy
no there's another one right there wow
that is
that is right there that is
and there's another fast token I think
that's yeah that's two okay so that's
good
there it is and I think this is the last
one of these types to get up here
besides fast tokens and the comic book
page downstairs and I'm really hoping I
won't have to backtrack anything for the
cameras
because I saw I saw it open with no door
Beyond it
oh no
[Music]
interesting that there's a plushie here
what are you doing don't worry this
won't have any actual lasting
repercussions okay so before I do candy
Cadet I know I have the tokens but
there's one more token to get
so I need to go get the last token
because I have
I have six and there's one more down
here so I'm gonna go get it and then
come back
oh why are there murders everywhere
it's like the inside of an oven
all right so that is all of the tokens
so now I can hear the full story and
that means you can too okay
lullaby to sing
one day the monster slopped curling and
instead this is
smart monsters
[Music]
oh is that the end of the story
so I got
I got all these tokens for nothing and I
could have heard the full story but
what was the point of all the tokens
take my tokens God damn it of
course all right fine there's another
thing over here right here
the last comic book page and I think
that minus the one collectible that's
there when you get all the other stuff
is everything so I can read this comic
in full wow look Gregory's running away
from something Gregory is hiding from
something Gregory is
talking to Freddy something oh wow must
have seen this mask before always so
creative then they're friends forever
and then vanny gets uh shreked and then
springtrap gets tricked uh well that's
cool and all but um
oh I still have to kiss voice box
well anyway so I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure that I got all the doors
unlocked however I still technically
have chica's voice box I'm not sure why
but I have it but I think I got what I
needed
pretty sure anyway
so let's give it a try
[Music]
yep
Gregory
are you in there stupid door won't open
you okay Greg
Greg
all right let's see if this worked I
have a funny feeling it won't
because that's how it goes
I
you're not Gregory
you don't know that what are you
um
get out of here run
what
can you hear me Gregory
is that really you
I mean really you
are trying to reach you all night I'm
not at the pizza place something's
trying to trick you you're a bit late
this thing in the basement sounds just
like you how do I know this is you for
real is there another option you need to
get out of there now
just follow instructions
what
what are you wearing
why are you different
why
why are you different that doesn't make
any sense this is a tall robot before
but that's something else
okay well anyway I'll run now
so
I can't remember where the door was but
I think it was up ahead here and I'm
guessing maybe
different costume because I did
something right
Maybe
yeah I'm going I'm going
I can't see anything
I'm trying
I know
so yeah okay so this should be open
right it is all the way all the way to
the back okay that's good to know
so I wasn't crazy and I don't have to go
back and do anything over again
whoa
yeah take a door idiot uh am I supposed
to be doing something I am really I'm
really floundering on this one
um
ah frick
huh
[Music]
foreign
so for some reason the enemy was in a
costume now that I did all of the things
to do it
but I when I didn't do it before it was
not in a costume and it was just a tall
Slenderman style robot and so it killed
it
the machine and then Gregory didn't send
me plummeting to my death which was very
weird like I get the whole thing where I
was being misled by fake Gregory the
whole time but in this case Gregory just
decided that I deserved to die which is
a bold thing for a child to decide but
there you have it so the moral of the
story is the true evil was inside
whatever costume that was all along just
like vanny and that's why the true
ending was Vani being disassembled by
staff Bots and just in that way
the staff claw
did that hey that guy
and nobody else
I know wait why didn't I get in
wait why didn't I get the one in nine ah
whatever it don't matter okay so that is
security Beach ruin now unless I'm
missing anything and I don't think I am
I've seen everything that there is for
this DLC to offer and I'd say for free
DLC which if you didn't know this DLC
was free if you own security breach that
was pretty good I think that the
developers really wanted to show that
they could make a cohesive scary
experience even if it was extremely
linear but I think like making it linear
and super linear was the best chance
they had to get it out quickly and I'm
like go for it that's great you just
iterate upon the designs you already had
the level designs and you just like
modify some assets you make some new
animations it's still a lot of work but
it's a lot better than trying to like
fix the open world situation that was
happening before not that they haven't
done some improvements I know that
there's been quite a few patches since
the last time that I played that I have
fixed things in security breach and I do
applaud them for that I think this was a
fantastic DLC minus the bugs of finding
secret stuff but that wasn't part of the
main experience and way
anyway good stuff it is good to come
back here and I know it was really fun
to meme on security breach when it first
came out but I wasn't joking when I said
I thought positively of it after I was
done playing it it was aggravating at
times but it had charm and I think
that's why it's memorable is because the
people that playing it they can Overlook
the bugs because so much love is clearly
woven into the game at every level
there's so much detail put into this
game almost too much detail to the
detriment but because the love was there
it's just like you know cooking and you
can't have a good meal without love
baked into it it was clearly love and
love for the franchise and love for Five
Nights at Freddy's in general and and I
think like that really showed and that's
what made it Charming it made choices
and sometimes the choices could be
debated whether they were good or not
but that doesn't change the fact that
there was still so much to see and you
could you could practically smell the
detail put into the game and that you
know that takes a lot of work and that
takes a lot of dedication and it takes a
team that actually really cares about it
so I'd say this is good security breach
when it came out it was flawed but it
was a flawed gem you know it wasn't a
turd that you polished it was a gem that
fell in the turd you know and you had to
dust it off a little bit ruin Embraces a
turd this analogy falls apart a little
bit but it was good so thank you
everybody so much for watching maybe
someday I'll go back and try to get some
security breach secrets that I didn't
get before
um but I think that ship has sailed and
that time has passed and this was good
to play I hear there's another VR
version coming out soon made by this
same team and if I remember help wanted
was pretty cool so I'll try that thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out the other scary games that I've done
check out distractible go my favorite
sports team with Bob Wade and Tyler
respectively check out anything else
that I'm doing I'm doing a whole lot
these days and I have a movie that's
going to be coming out real soon thank
you and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]